columbia university libraries is proud
to announce a powerful new search tool
that's optimized to get you the
resources you need faster than ever clio
beta harnesses advanced state-of-the-art
web tools that enable you to search
filter and access the more than 10
million items available to you at
columbia university the brand new search
interface showcases a clean modern
design and enables simultaneous
exploration of many different kinds of
resources books articles newspapers
dissertations archives databases DVDs
websites and so much more Cleo beta
helps you intuitively narrow down your
search results to find exactly what you
need for example you can filter by
format publication date author location
language or topic you can even perform
your search in different resources
without having to start over Cleo beta
is also smarter depending on the type of
resource you're looking for the
availability citation information
including tables of contents and request
options are specifically tailored to
that item now you can always know the
quickest and most efficient way to get
what you need and you can help us
improve this new tool by using the
feedback tab on every page your feedback
is important to ensure we give you the
best search experience possible try it
now at Cleo beta columbia edu